your new movie irresistible which by the
way I should say premieres this Friday
he gets Steve Carell because you worked
with him and stuff you go to him did you
always have him in mind or did you have
another after I wrote it I didn't have
anybody else involved until I sent it to
Steve so Steve is the one who read it
and went yeah I would like to do this
I'm imagining you on the set of your new
movie sitting in that director's chair
that where's my grapes
I got limited time here you [ __ ]
whatever I need to do fires oh is it
great telling her oh hey take it down a
notch you know what I mean you're a
little bit over the top here I mean that
dude made my life so easy on set I can't
even tell a couple of people like Joe
Scarborough and Mika they appear in the
film and that I find that fun I didn't
want it to be overly populated with that
like if you notice in the movie there's
an MSNBC anchor a CNN anchor and a Potts
anchor and it's actually the same woman
and she's always just in different ways
and Rises her name is always Brooke so
stupid stuff like that in it I hope
people watch the movie now he's even
thinking with this Kovan 19 there's been
no big movie premiere right you don't
have the red carpet and Carell walks
around and all the stars walk around and
you get interviewed it may be one of the
worst effects of this pandemic
I know people don't talking about it
about how directors are not getting
their due with a big red carpet yes you
know because I see a lot of coverage of
your suffering front lines euros and all
these people dying but such little
concern what about you like you sit
there but two years of your life and
your big party you're not getting your
big party for your movie parties nice
for the people but to be perfectly
honest like the promotion you you know
me well enough to know that going out
and promoting is that's the one I always
get in trouble because I'll say
something that you know is stupid and
everybody will jump on it maybe it's
better you don't have a
premiere it's gonna go from we haven't
heard from this guy in five years so
exciting to see him back - will you
please shut the [ __ ]